you cannot manage what you don't measure  people's time is the most expensive and  valuable asset in the company and this  is the secret way that geotab goes to  markets we work very closely with the  customers we understand we started  thinking about what do we do really well  over the twenty years ago we've helped  you all stay agile and productivity  fleet safety compliance sustainability  every one in five trucks that you see on  the road today in North America has a  geotab device in store it's amazing this  is the very vibrant very healthy  ecosystem we need to think about what is  the future of connective transportation  the year 2020 and it's time to launch a  sixth pillar the sustainability pillar  we have to open our customers minds to  the art of the possible  this is the future  [Music]